So when they needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could.
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
deadpool 3 video for marvel kevin feige just did
a bunch of big interviews where he explained
what's going on with all their marvel phase
4 marvel phase 5 movies he even talked about new
x-men movies so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get the videos i'll be doing videos for all the
big marvel phase 4 series all the episodes and
all the movies that they're releasing this year
finally actually releasing movies we're doing
a disney plus giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and let me know
which characters you want to see cross over
into deadpool 3. but if you have no idea what's
going on the big announcement that kevin feige
just made is that deadpool 3 will be rated r and
it'll be set inside the mcu in a much bigger way
than any of us expected so it was a bit of a
surprise just because the deadpool movies are
such a hard r even though ryan reynolds per his
comments said that they leave a lot of stuff on
the cutting room floor there are a lot of jokes
that they wind up cutting out of the movies
yeah you could fill a gymnasium with some of the
jokes that got cut out of deadpool one and two
that would get us all arrested or turned into some
sort of disney liquid and previously everything
that kevin feige had said implied that disney
wanted all their proper mcu marvel movies the
real big ones to be firmly pg-13 just to maximize
the potential amount of money that they could earn
they want you buying four tickets for all your
family members they don't want you just buying two
tickets to their movies my stunt man's about to
you up but this is kevin feige's official
statement he says it will be rated r and we
are working on a script right now and ryan
reynolds is overseeing the script right now it
will not be filming this year ryan is a very busy
very successful actor we've got a number of things
we've already announced that we now actually have
to make but it's exciting for it to have begun
again a very different type of character in the
mcu and ryan is a force of nature as we can all
see which is just awesome to see him bring that
character to life they actually announced a
little while ago that they hired the writers
from the bob's burgers tv show i don't know much
about the writers themselves but it's a great
show so i'm sure they'll do something really cool
with the movie but the reason why ryan reynolds
is overseeing the script himself is because
he's become so powerful with the success of the
deadpool movies so he has a lot of control over
what the story is what they do with the character
and what they do with the overall look and feel of
the movie as well we have that new fantastic four
movie coming up obviously kevin feige announced
originally deadpool 2 was going to be a big
fantastic four movie crossover but it was going to
be fox's 2015 version of the fantastic four so to
give you an example of how powerful ryan reynolds
has become that was when tim miller was still on
the project remember he wound up leaving deadpool
too because basically ryan reynolds wanted to
take the movie in a different direction and do all
the x-force stuff that you wound up seeing he was
always really involved with that first deadpool
movie but after the first one blew up that's
when the studio pretty much told him he could do
whatever he wanted and even though kevin feige
and marvel probably will have notes about how they
cross over with mcu stuff mostly ryan reynolds is
still pretty much allowed to do whatever he wants
to with the movie so even though it's marvel and
kevin feige's movie ryan reynolds himself is also
just as responsible for the creative of the film
the reason why he said they're not filming
the movie till next year in 2022 is because
ryan reynolds announced like a billion different
movies that he's making the next couple of years
so that just means they're going to finish the
script in the story this year film deadpool 3
next year and then release it sometime during 2023
so the earliest that deadpool 3 could potentially
come out would be that february 2023 date in this
marvel phase 5 schedule they announced so zoom in
in hands here we actually know what a lot of
these mystery movies are going to be so for
example there's no more february 2022 movie that's
doctor strange two multiverse of madness and it's
coming out in march may 2022 is thor four love and
thunder july is black panther two kevin feige also
said a lot about what's going on with the story
of black panther two and how that's going to be
different because of chadwick boseman's passing
i'll probably do a separate video about that at
some point in the future too then there's no more
october movie but they are doing captain marvel 2
in november then now we actually have four
different marvel movies competing for release
dates in 2023 there's ant-man in the wasp3 quantum
mania that'll probably be the february movie
but then there's guardians of the galaxy 3 that'll
probably wind up being a spring or summer movie
either the may or the july date then the new
fantastic four movie that'll probably wind up
being a summer movie meaning the deadpool 3 would
either be that november movie date that they have
on the schedule or they give it one of the earlier
dates and just shuffle the other movies around a
little like guardians 3 could probably come out
anywhere in this schedule fantastic four though
is probably gonna be one of their most hyped
up films during that year so that's probably
gonna get one of the summer dates but when kevin
feige said that ryan reynolds deadpool is a very
different type of character in the mcu that's
what all the news outlets are citing as him
saying that deadpool will be in the mcu what that
means though is that there really aren't any other
characters in the mcu outside of maybe spider-man
who have the potential to be this wise cracking
tone but also break the fourth wall in so far
from what we've seen in the spider-man movies tom
holland's spider-man character has not broken the
fourth wall yet there's been a lot of references
to meta things in easter eggs like the tobey
maguire spider-man movies with j jonah jameson
showing up and through all the spider-burst things
that are supposedly going on around the spider-man
3 movie kevin feige also said that a lot of those
rumors are true he said some of them are false
but some of them are true so there probably is
some spider-verse stuff happening during that
but none of those easter eggs or those references
are really big fourth wall breaks in the
traditional sense the fourth wall break is really
like when deadpool turns to the camera addresses
the audience and then addresses the fact that
he's a fictional character in a movie so you have
to picture a big avengers movie like avengers 5 or
avengers secret wars where you have this giant big
action scene and then it pans the deadpool and he
turns to the audience and just comments on the big
battle that's happening like can you believe that
this is happening what's going to happen though
because the movie will be rated r thankfully he
confirmed is that it kind of limits the crossovers
that they can do with avengers characters the way
that those go down deadpool can reference anything
he wants everyone including disney people in real
life like kevin feige even stan lee may he rest
in peace wow nice suit zip it stanley deadpool can
make fun of all the mcu movies he can make fun of
iron man dying snapping in avengers end game and
he can make fun of the fact that he himself is not
getting paid as much as robert downey jr got paid
to make the marvel movies but like robert downey
jr himself wooden cameo spider-man is also kind
of a harder self because i know everyone wants
to see deadpool and spider-man cross over when
you talk about spider-man showing up in movies
the thing about that is you have to get sony
involved and get them to approve what you do
with the character because they technically still
own it even though they're sharing him with marvel
so if we see any kind of big deadpool spider-man
crossover it would be more likely that it would be
deadpool crossing over in a small cameo during a
spider-man movie instead of the other way around
like they meet each other during avengers 5
then later deadpool pops up in a spider-man
credit scene of some kind just in a later movie
the other funny thing that they can do that's kind
of a workaround for this is they can actually have
tom holland help promote deadpool 3 like he can do
the funny videos that hugh jackman does with ryan
reynolds all the time and if you remember a couple
years ago they actually did a big spider-man name
drop during a deadpool trailer when they were
promoting deadpool 2. so deadpool has referenced
spider-man before phone it in listen this thing
only goes to 11 so beat it spider-man god i should
have asked nsync the other big thing about marvel
releasing a rated r movie and actually putting
a marvel studios logo on it is that it actually
gives a lot of people hope that they might
do the new blade movie with mahershala ali
as a rated r film and speaking of blade wesley
snipes made a twitter post the other day
responding to a fan saying that he would always be
blade so wouldn't it be cool if he actually cameos
in a future movie as the blade from a different
universe because so much of marvel phase 4 is
relying on all these big multiverse tropes during
a recent press junket for Wandavision kevin feige
also refused to explain when they're transitioning
from marvel phase 4 to marvel phase 5 but i do
feel like by the time we get to deadpool 3 we
will be in marvel phase 5 territory most of
marvel phase 4 especially starting in Wandavision
is all sort of setting up the concept of mutants
inside the mcu mutates or however you want to
think about it deadpool is technically a mutate
which is a little bit different from a mutant
but he is an x-men character so i'll explain
the differences between all those things during
the Wandavision episode videos that i do because
kevin feige also did kind of confirm because of
all the house of m's stuff that they're doing in
Wandavision that it would also help slowly set up
the new version of the x-men movies that they're
going to be doing inside the mcu eventually he
said behind the scenes they've spent a lot of time
talking about their new x-men movie that they're
developing but they haven't announced any kind of
director or castings or anything like that so even
though we're going to hear all this fantastic four
movie stuff in the next couple of years it'll be
a while before we hear legit mcu x-men stuff but
there'll be a lot of easter eggs in the marvel
phase four project so i'll just point those out
as they show up in movies and disney plus series
the other thing they're probably gonna wind up
doing is they probably will do the once upon a
deadpool treatment for deadpool 3 release a pg-13
cut of deadpool 3 after the r-rated cut comes
out in theaters the funny thing about once upon a
deadpool though is they actually were making that
while the fox disney deal was in the process of
finalizing so that's why ryan reynolds actually
referenced all the disney stuff during those
promos i've already done videos about how i want
them to do the story of deadpool 3 as deadpool
kills the fox marvel universe they haven't made
any confirmations about that but if they want to
swerve on that he could actually just show up at
the beginning of his movie with a bunch of x-men
easter eggs from the fox movies just acknowledging
that he probably did kill off all those characters
but everybody post all your story pitches for
deadpool 3 what do you want the story of the movie
to be what'll happen is there were so many other
big marvel movie announcements in the past couple
of days i'll try to do videos for the biggest
stuff in the next couple of days but Wandavision
episode 1 and episode 2 are releasing on friday so
my full episode videos for those will post every
friday just like the mandalorian episodes while
you wait for everything click here for that funny
deadpool 3 monologue video that ryan reynolds
just posted and click here for my non-spoilery
early Wandavision review thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and maximum effort!